e aí a briga deixou ronaldo com vocês
estou feliz demais achou ligar
posicionado aqui ontem e não ao de maio
ampliou
eu estou muito feliz falou estou melhor
do que eu tô um pouco doente a esse
assunto o vídeo eu quero dizer a galera
de são caetano do sul abc hospital dinho
quer dizer a galera de são caetano do
sul são paulo que amanhã sexta 16 de
outubro fazendo show aí no teatro paulo
machado de carvalho às 20 horas botar
essa tela preta para encher o saco de
vocês e passando esse final de semana no
próximo eu sou todo o paraná
a inspeção do paraná e todo mundo se
liga e vai comprar ingresso como é que
faz só entra nesse site que está
aparecendo aqui ou clicar no primeiro
link da inscrição desse vídeo beleza é
nóis eu fiz um vídeo foi coisa de mulher
o vídeo sucesso bombom na net a galera
curtiu muito a galera falou assim eles
faltam você falar coisas de homem só vou
falar aqui de coisas de homem eu posso
falar com propriedade sobre isso porque
eu sou um homem né
um parece mas o primeira coisa que eu
acho engraçado sobre homem é uma coisa
que eu não entendo é porque é que deus a
grafia alguns homens com a barba tão
linda e outros com tão pouco né gente
olha isso aqui também disse que é uma
vergonha
andando pelo shopping eu vejo carbono
chamada paradinha emitiu fica assim eu
ficar assim meu deus sabe me seguro
podem esfregar minha casa na barra desse
cara que tem um cara que nas com a barba
sabe aquela barba amiga bárbara amiga
unida afirmou período juntinho do outro
o meu nome ao país que nasce intrigado
ação pela ac aparece outro pelo pai na
sexta com rapidez pela que a enaac óbvio
o melhor disco votar porque porque a
pessoa que vê se pela aqui e venci pela
aqui eu não imaginei que isso é uma
barba a imagem que o pêlo avulso nasceu
está conversando aqui pois é não sei
quem vai falar da onu que tinha um
cabelinho quis aqui é minha barba sakala
eu acho muito engraçado e homem é o
seguinte todo mundo sabe que o nosso
órgão genital ele tem somente um caninho
né é um buraquinho por onde sai o mijo
só que de manhã cedo esse buraco se
multiplica o cara leva a família a
comissão já fraca o placar o cara tem
que escolher qual já que ele quer que o
botafogo era privada que o outro vai
cair fora eu achei estranho porque às
vezes a 1 já pra cá outra cai fica
pingando mesmo assim por baixo agora
lascou furacão foi o ovo não tinha casa
própria
bota duas privado o que eu tô aqui caiu
já parou pra cá e se ficar pingando uma
tupiniquim baixo alami rola outra coisa
nós que eu acho estranho até
constrangedor que na maioria dos casos
quando a gente acorda gente agora com um
negócio duro parecendo um martelo de
thor só que eu acho interessante que ele
não acorda meio duro não acorda assim a
pô
todo mundo aqui tem negado pela corte
parcial sobre cheguei nessa [ __ ] eu
cabo vai pro banheiro só que quando
cavaco olha o negócio duro acontece cada
com incidência na vida da gente que fala
assim o senhor porque isso aqui tá
acontecendo cara sempre que o cara
acorda com um negócio duro ontem visita
em casa ou a mãe limpando a casa e
quando tem jeito eu ia ficar no banheiro
se torna a mais longa caminhada da paz
catar empurrando tão tão distante do
cheque o cara tem que se virar na
desculpa eu dormi mal jeito que o
douglas costa é clara ninguém é e que a
mãe da gente ela percebe isso e toda vez
que há muita gente vê que a gente
acordou com um negócio duro e ela
percebe que a gente tá com vergonha ela
sempre uma piadinha ele a receber este
ano eu te criei eu tive a vida podia
pelada que já que quer ver rosé tua
vontade de dizer mãe a senhora me viu
quando era pequeno eu cresci o bb
cresceu aqui junto comigo aqui ó
dependendo da posição que eu tô aqui o
som leva a legenda e mais arrastando a
senhora me rola que a mãe do tema dentro
é outra coisa com as bem interessante eu
acho até um pouco estranhas idioma é um
segredo nosso é um segredo que eu vou
botar pra vocês que são mulheres eu
quero que vocês saibam que vocês mortes
punindo o que a gente gosta disso é uma
coisa nossa todo homem gosta do cheiro
da sua própria roupa aymond marino tempo
amor de carinho cada ataque de boi
parrish no ensino no youtube chega
recheada de rotina e bota a mão dentro
da calça que a roda do carro a bolinha
epa está cabisbaixa a distância
utilidade agora o que a gente faz a
gente abre moto dele aqui só impressa ou
digital que o exame biométrico e fecha o
dedo dela e puxa que ele vem puxando
aquele cheiro delicioso canal conferida
vez a mãe está por pet e irmão tão perto
doyle na grã bretanha em apa é bom de
maia pai do eto o homem gosta do cheiro
da sua própria roupa da sua própria e
rola não é da rua domingo você nunca vai
ver um amigo do carro assim a paz como é
que taxa vai pegar a gata lixou escola
cheiroso a massa pode não tem nunca
vocês agora da nossa é discutir agora
quer saber uma coisa que te ama muito e
sabe uma coisa que a gente gosta quer
saber o quanto a gente fica forro mesmo
que coisa massa é o seguinte de vez em
quando dá uma coceirinha do ovo é o que
é isso em que a doença é nunca às vezes
a vida a vida ver que você tá com o
órgão genital muito parados há não se
acaba que utilizando vamos dar uma
brincadeira e pela animação zinho que a
vida faz ela da página que o ator seria
tão gostosa do ovo no ovo no saque o ovo
do cabo que é o ovo é porque o caba não
dói muito pagar é albino é o bi no
cabula ainda que seria que o que acaba
faz cara pega ocorrendo lado porém do
outro passinho e também manto é do inter
sensação melhor não cara é isso aí se
você tiver gostar desse vídeo já sabe o
que fazer se você tiver no youtube é só
clicar aqui e gostei
e se você tiver no facebook é só clicar
em curtir e marcar um amigo seu dos
comentários que se identifica com esse
vídeo que você quer saber de tudo que eu
tô fazendo qualquer hora em qualquer
momento tempo real é só você me seguir
no inep chat que está aparecendo aqui em
cima o melhor é muito fácil você vem
aqui ó até mais fácil você vem aqui no 6
nep clica aqui na câmara é o babá agora
você posiciona câmera aqui agora você
aponta a câmera papela e foca vai
aparecer você adicionou o imunes que sou
eu então aí muito obrigado a assistir
vídeo até aqui valeu é nóis pmdb